i test final eight nome harry likes
e labs e ne siate e questo e cricche
we've been to the spider della gt
ragazzi uniti questo video sono fatti j
oggi siamo in un nuovo logo per
ricominciare ragazzi come sento dire di
partire con la parola della settimana
che questa settimana è stata vinta dai
viola è veramente figo allora gaona big
news
anzi più che bigg epic big news di 20
ragazzi la produzione del film regalato
a noi che abbiamo fatto appunto il film
week end ad ibiza che praticamente
questo weekend qua quindi questo sabato
e questa domenica voglio fare un blog
coi contro maroni quindi lega spero di
riuscire a farlo è tra poco arriverà
quello di pizzo tenetevi pronti perchè
sarà una roba se non vado a merda prima
tra l'altro ragazzi mi sono veramente
ammazzato instillò anzi tra ieri e oggi
perché mi sono beccato e cielo anche
adesso la febbre a 40 però non so perché
ora ho la febbre però se non registro
poi mi venite coi forconi giù dalla
finestra quindi cerco di fare lo stesso
i video ovviamente per una [ __ ] volta
che vado a ibiza ma che cosa mi potrebbe
mai venire se non la febbre in questo
momento non si vede che ho la febbre
perché prima di fare questo video mi
sono bombato di aspirina a manetta e
l'effetto dovrebbe durare un'oretta
circa quindi meglio che muovo al culo
questo fine settimana ho fatto light
therapy dei consiste appunto nello stare
un giorno senza tecnologia infatti dalla
finanza poi ho preso la febbre e questo
ragazzi è più o meno riassunto di quello
che è successo a balzi tabacchi un 5 non
poco socievole
addio iniziava sembrando la coppa cosa
può fare una persona senza tecnologia
durante la giornata io la risposta cielo
quanto amo gli scoiattoli ragazzi è
stato a parte tutto veramente ma
veramente bellissimo poter vivere una
giornata senza tecnologia a mio parere
male non può assolutamente fare se
provato per un giorno quindi ragazzi se
vi capita fatelo con ragazzi oggi non
farò lo scarta joe dei fatti perché non
ho più vecchi perché quelli che avevo
gli o finiti grazie a dio quindi almeno
adesso posso sta tranquillo evo lui
invece passare a farli risponde perché
sa le domande troppo strane
effettivamente la prima domanda arriva
da maria che mi chiede perché i dossi
sempre le magliette che ospita fa vj e
non metti mai quelle che ti compro tua
mamma spolli chat
io metto le mie magliette perché faccio
i video sono fa vj o nel caso non lo
sapessi piacere fa vigenti e magliette
lo rimette quelle di willwoosh lillo che
vuoi vedermi cambiar magliette perché so
che 10th mentre mi spoglio maniche corte
ciò la febbre li mortacci mia io ragazzi
non possiedo maglietta a maniche lunghe
non ce le ho le mani quindi se ho la
febbre sono morto anche questo non me
l'ha comprata mia madre ma sono comprata
io però io non metto mai magliette che
mi compro io perché facciamo video con
le mie magliette di solito chiusa la
questione perché ti fai queste paranoie
fratello ci dovrebbe essere scritto jobs
però non riesco a storcere il braccio
poi risponde che sono affatto alla fine
tua madre per la torta sul mobile prima
era era c'erano i pezzettoni che erano
così guai
[Musica]
c'è un motivo se ho la febbre
potrebbe essere che mi abbia sbattuto
fuori di casa facendomi dormire per
strada in mutande ma quello è un altro
discorso prima che studiano qual è la
tua band preferita so quanti miliardi di
volte l'ho già detto per pentatonica
alessandro breve ma quando scorre ogni
volta per trovare quelle giuste allora
in realtà ha ragione nel senso che io
allora per trovare non è facile trovare
domande giuste in italia vita solo in
italia esclusivamente in italia le
domande sono 44 esattamente 4 che
squadra tifi hai mai fatto sesso sei
fidanzato preferisci la nutella o la
patata più ammazzerei tutti quelli che
mi fanno ste domanda vi risponde ma la
frase bella ragazzi l'hai sentita da
un'altra persona oppure ti è venuta di
tool spontanea volontà come lo sperma
ciano parla ti fai un duetto con un
cantante famoso ascom e io conosco
personalmente jessie j perché ha la j
alla fine del nome quindi fa vj jessie j
abbiamo fatto un duetto su skype e
questo è il video anch'essi che ha messo
intricata che nesta
[Musica]
ok gli staufer
a
[Musica]
[Applauso]
bionda
piazza
[Musica]
a time
i ragazzi direi che posso concludere qui
l'episodio spero che video vi sia
piaciuto è strano che io l'abbia
registrato con la febbre
avevo lasciato l'arma di aperto rimini
si è vista tutta la biancheria però che
vi sia piaciuto ragazzi prima di
concludere faccio come al solito farvi
domanda fare domanda di oggi è adesso
che sono finiti i pacchi che cosa posso
scartare nei blog o alle cose sconce ve
lo dico i ragazzi prima di concludere vi
chiedo scusa se con un po più morto però
la febbre anche se registro lo stesso
che è disumano comunque sia non soffro
un bel po quindi scusatemi se non sono
stato al top delle mie performance spero
che ha visto vi si apre sul tecnico ma
sento sei video è piaciuta ragazzina
certo punto è un mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook che come noi video
tratte da tiziana sono travestiti se non
ci vediamo al posto dei ragazzi